this is Startalk hey I'm Chuck nice and
I'm sitting here with dr. Neil deGrasse
Tyson and you know we have a very
special star talk all-stars episode for
you and that is because what you're
going to hear actually came out of the
star talk all-stars leap into launch
party which happened on February 29th a
year ago and I'm sitting here with dr.
Neil deGrasse Haider now dude that
relief here hey I look at you so get you
out my smart and um a close thing
happened at the end of the party which
was it was you Mike Massimino is another
good friend of yours
dr. David Grinspoon who is dr. funky
spoon he's going on Twitter happy spoon
on Twitter and and we all set to MSME it
was astral Mike
so Michael on Twitter yeah and we all
sat down and we were drinking some
drinks and just really talking about
pretty much everything and exactly yeah
and it was a cool conversation we talked
about everything from what actually
makes space travel which you had a very
interesting point of view because most
of us just kind of go up in the air and
it would come back down hmm that's not
really space trapped no not no no no and
for me even just going into Earth orbit
is not space true right not really going
anywhere right driving around the block
if you see and you know how far it is to
space to where the space station it's
about the distance from here to
Washington DC lah up straight up does it
sound so impressive when you say it like
that so I am just I'm saying yeah and so
now you can look at a school room globe
and ask how high above a school room
globe is it
it's about 3/8 of an inch so if you took
3/8 of an inch and you hovered a little
model right above a schoolroom globey
space according to NASA and everybody's
state of mind right well so we're barely
even in the water on the on the beach
with a kid on the shores or a cosmic
ocean
we have we have barely touched the phone
so we get so we kind of have a toe in
the foam and that's about foam not even
all 10 yeah right
god that's just the read so this is why
I wrote a whole book called well I wrote
a book with the title delusions of space
enthusiasts right okay no no the title
is failure to launch share you to launch
and then the publisher that we can have
the word failure right put that in the
title right so they renamed it but in
there I just talked about here's a
reality check on everybody's everybody's
sense of what space is so they renamed
it space chronicles facing the ultimate
frontier right but so I I try to put a
reality check on everybody's statement
that they've made about space Wow yeah
pretty cool so we talked about that we
talked about so many other things that I
mean we just got into it basically we
were sitting around getting a little
toasty and shooting the crap catch you
in space fat you're in space back and so
now some of you may have already seen
this on Startalk all-access comm for
those of you who are unfamiliar with
Startalk all-access comm it is a
subscription service that allows you to
see everything that we do commercial
free it also allows you to see what
you're going to listen to right now
which is exclusive original content that
you won't find anywhere else and you can
also once you subscribe watch everything
that we do on roku Amazon fire and Apple
TV so it's a very cool service start
talking all access comm you should
subscribe and check it out so if you
want to know what it feels like to sit
down and have a drink with an astronaut
and astrobiologist and an astrophysicist
who just happens to be the world's
foremost science educator and also some
other dude then this this is for you and
a comedian oh yeah and a comedian and
some comedian this is for you so with
that um let's do this let's do this
all right so we are here at the startup
all-stars party and I'm sitting right
now with a the actual all-star of
all-stars which is our progenitor and
that would be dr. Neil deGrasse Tyson
are you not thank that are you not are
you not the progenitor of Startalk
pleased that we intercepted it well you
know what I don't want to call you dad I
got father issues okay now here's the
deal uh so you know I thought it'd be
great to uh first of all end with some
entertainment and that's why we have dr.
funky spoon here okay
and I also Twitter handle dr. dr.
fuckless David Grinspoon under David
grin seating has dr. funky spoon yeah
and so uh you know one of the people to
help make the party good because they
gave us some free alcohol and that was
yeah I go how we roll so here's what I
thought would be a great way to end so
we have Ninkasi Brewing Company ground
control which is an Imperial Stout that
they actually donated to us and the
great thing about this beer maybe it's
great married maybe it's not I'm not
sure
they took strains of yeast to outer
space they grew those strings of yeast
in outer space brought them back to
earth and then brewed beer why wait so
Mike was that on your mission no root
beer is that why the Hubble telescope
got messed up our mission you know if
you'd be really pissed at us that we
make that is so right no did not do that
it was not okay let the record show that
your mission did not grew beer busy
helping out the astronomy world's in the
Hubble one of the cool thing where did
this come from and what is this what
flight was it on where's this where's
their proof you want some documentation
because you anyway Chuck sent out what
you want documentation so here's the
deal the reason why I have you here is
because allegedly there are only two
things in this room that have been in
outer space this beer and you all right
okay
and we can't drink you so that's why
this is here a good beer dude okay it's
where it's very dense it's kind of like
a Guinness kind of yes entity and
viscosity to it Oh
it tastes good and it works and it's got
a sustained bubbly head on top has a
Guinness wood is a little sweeter than
Guinness yeah it has the bitter backdrop
but on the front end there's a sweetness
that cuts the bitterness in the way you
might drop a touch of sugar into coffee
I don't know why but I want to have sex
with this beer I'm not sure what the
hell Neal is talking about but I want to
date this beer okay so now these are my
tasting notes that's all no no no
actually everything you said was
actually spot-on and in addition to the
fact that of course you being an
astrophysicist you being an astronaut
dr. David Grinspoon is an astrobiologist
and so all are you call him doctor and
not as doctor you know because you know
he's got the funky spoon if you change
his moniker is they've got a point you
know when you come up if I call dr.
deGrasse then you'll be calling me
doctor but I see the grass but it's not
rice Neil deGrasse so I thought it week
very cool if you know the fact that all
three of you tie into this that we were
all here to close out our star talk
all-stars party and David's going to
sing a little song that kind of ties us
all in which is the astrobiologist blues
astrobiology blues yeah yeah blues is my
favorite musical genre really yes yes oh
wait so he'll be after this yeah I know
I was going to say like I hate to
disappoint beautified help either way
just just to get some of his resume on
the table yeah he cut his teeth thinking
about and writing about Venus we got a
book you buy a book about Venus that he
wrote yes the Venus is like 900 degrees
if it is a no life on Venus so I don't
know how he got from Venus to
astrobiology how did that happen well
it's a long story
never mind you know you know Venus
started out as just a fine planet like
the rest of them and something something
went wrong one bannerino biologist
really want to figure that one out
okay let this happen to your planet okay
wow this is a runaway greenhouse effect
yes yeah Clark I'd say some quick about
Venus I had I once calculated how long
it would take to cook a 16 inch
pepperoni pizza just sticking it out on
the window sill on Venus just like and I
got nine seconds Wow right because of
how high the temperature is and how
dense the atmosphere is it all seems
long what so here's I'm saying so here's
I'm saying is I'm saying so at a hundred
times the atmospheric pressure nearly a
hundred times and it had the molecules
would be imparting heat to the pizza
faster than they would on earth just
because of the air pressure we kept the
temperature rises the air pressure right
add to higher temperature 900 degrees
it's like hotter than a pizza oven as we
cooked the pizza down on the windowsill
nine seconds or more proud of this so I
tweeted nine seconds okay then Nathan
Myhrvold called me out this is a
physicist turned chef he he took all the
laboratory equipment that is in a
chemist and physicist lab and brought it
into his kitchen and so now when he
cools food he brings it down like liquid
nitrogen temperature when he cuts food
he'll cut one who's a microtome which
cuts one cell layered thick of food that
it operates on your tongue when it takes
so I'm not gonna lie he sounds like it
did yeah he's kind of a hole yeah I'm
just sorry I go to that right I'm down
I'm not trying to eat in his place so
Dawson appears yeah not hears I'm saying
so I thought our badass coming up with
the nine seconds he said I you left out
a factor in your calculation and that is
the radiative in the radiative effect of
the Atmos just that the atmosphere is at
a temperature so it's not simply the
movement of the molecules of the air it
is radiating infrared photons at the
pizza in addition so that molecules
hitting this is why when someone walks
between you and a fire you instantly
feel cooler right you're cooler it's not
that the air change temperature in a
fraction of a second time
tons of black people read Quahog and
they're getting blocked by by the person
walk between you and the fire okay so if
you add that in takes two seconds to
cook the pizza right so now here comes
our way on this is well let's wait I'm
just going to say this and the way off
I'm going to say this second is a piece
of charcoal I'll I'm going to say that's
only or your entire story just confirmed
he's a dick that's what what a good was
now I'm good I think that's actually
fascinating what what he did was I mean
what's fun it I love being corrected by
more science oh yeah that's nice that is
just because I'll put in everything I
know
right and obviously I want what I did to
be correct even if it's incomplete
so my calculation is correct but it's
missing this other part that he put in
and and it's ours wrong okay that's what
makes you a scientist and not a
Republican all right
not I'm sorry I'm not a dick right and
yeah okay
i solicit Abraham Lincoln was a
Republican
the first Republican President Jeff why
I only switched out okay Natalie I was
going to say that there's a history
there but I'm not going on there I'm
adding that I go there what is it what
is what does it matter sir mr. astronaut
dude the only man who's like been
weightless orbiting Earth one of the 547
people and whether we were talking about
this earlier yeah only four astronauts
only 547 people have actually been to
outer space we're not talking about the
pilot to get in the atmosphere people
are still in the atmosphere orbiting
Earth orbiting our orbit is it just
going us well no going to spin x-15 guys
you know the xref you guys know they're
part of the scott carpenter scott
Carpenter incarnated a suborbital even
Alan Shepard okay so those guys are part
of it because they're out of the
atmosphere that right all right how did
the atmosphere you've been a speaker but
it firsthand on that well if you want to
say being a race is simply being we'll
get back to you in a while yes okay if
you if you want to say that being in
space means you left Earth's atmosphere
okay define as 100 kilometres of 62
miles okay
in principle I don't have a problem with
that
cept it's the atmosphere worth thinner
then being in space would be a little
closer to Earth event half the
atmospheric pressure we do right being
in space would be at 50 kilometers or
just 30 miles up if it had a tenth the
ad then it would be six miles up if we
had a hundred it would be six tenths of
one mile up did I do the math on that
yeah close up close up if we had no
atmosphere we'd be here right now we'd
all be astronauts
right so then if I had a million dollars
and I was a better lover I wouldn't be
sitting here right now okay so so like
another so yeah yeah we reserve that we
need to go there right now right matter
right now so that's why I want to think
of space yep as those who have achieved
orbit okay leave me a favor wait wait
wait which which is a definition
independent of the atmospheric pressure
here on this planet
okay that's that's actually a very good
school that's a qualifying statement and
I like it what is it what is it we have
a minimum altitude to retain orbit is
there well you don't want otherwise
atmosphere burned you know messes
where's to worry so in principle I don't
know why you can't do orbit 100 miles up
what's that you there Roger and
languages gotta Emory letting us know
the real deal we're all in space all the
tests and identity the lowest altitude
orbit we've had with the show could be
for today whoa yeah yeah so you are one
of 533 people who have actually been
orbited orbit that I go I've been in
space yeah according to Neil deGrasse
Tyson you have one in five my definitely
it's an interesting definition you're
going to cut out a few people I
understand that but it's tough it's okay
so so here's my point so let me ask you
if you if you breed yeast and space it's
just breeding at zero-g is there
anything that you think would be
different in space there's a higher
radiation oh yeah they probably would if
they'd be interested to see how they did
this if it was exposed if it was it
probably was not Outsiders but I don't
know I'm guessing
you might have been on a space station
flight I don't know where they okay they
got this so I don't know enough about
yeast does yeast grow like a what is it
a plant because I know we've grown we've
grown plants wonder what the heck is
east okay he's all right what is you
have no idea what you're talking about
what is yeah when you grow each side you
grow yeast it's like let me ask you a
different question with more it's not a
growing plant it
well you're the astrobiologists because
like the plan okay so for plants first
you have 40% of our DNA identical with
that of yeast don't we but it but it
grows that's a real yeah yes well if it
grows what would be interesting is that
it's why a rose on our bodies is it have
a heavy so we have a heavy stalk or
anything to make it very it's physically
very simple okay so if it buddy grows
you'll see what do you see you see like
a plan give me help me out here just
cells it's just a mass of cells okay so
it's not really like a sunflower a
little structure now okay right so
that's simple
or simple so I don't I don't think it
would grow but he's from the east
consume sugar rise it can and women very
uncomfortable by somebody had to go
there you know what somebody who can boo
me all you want but I didn't say
anything and you got exactly what I was
talking about so I would think it grows
I think it sounds like a little
experiment that would grow the same way
if it was a plant like growing a plant
like a sunflower sunflowers have been
grown in space so sunflower on the earth
as a big stalk it's really really large
it doesn't need all that strength in
space it doesn't need that to hold
itself up so it grows with a very thin
stalk and it kind of winds itself around
it's very interesting but I'm thinking
in cases probably not much different so
it might be kind of a gimmick but it's
good beer it's good radiation but so
these are yeast that are the yeast in
here have their lives traceable to yeast
that were created in space yes from
yeast that was originally from Earth
right or sir I think it's a novelty the
novelty it's not gonna give me any of it
to him as a novelty I'm sure it's pretty
cool yeah yeah I think they actually
admit that it was a novelty because they
say that the reason why they did the
entire the entire novelty the the
experiment whatever you want to call it
is because they want to show people that
they're about exploration okay
all about explorations a good thing so
that that was the entire marketing
Goldwater's guys you know friends of
yours are stuff no I don't know them at
all coming really gave us free beer and
an optional it is very easy to inscri
the really where we agree here man right
yeah takes right now we'll do a whole
program show product I just murdered my
mom because I was a drinker you'll be in
space man
all right let's lift so so this is the
world premiere of the astrobiologist
Blues written by oh nice way what was
supposed to know that part well but I I
Co Co wrote it to some degree
okay good so you messed around with it
that I notice around with it but really
the consideration is around bar that's
around by dr. Duncan all right what's
the minutes again this is though how to
add my eyes all right all right so we're
going to be interesting because
astrobiology of this something like this
[Applause]
[Music]
everywhere that I go
it's doc what do you do what I look for
life in the cosmos
maybe that laughs looking for you are we
alone maybe but not for long well I got
those astrobiologists ooh that's why I
sing that's when the aliens come will
they come and pee oh well they make us
their pets and put it on a lead oh are
we alone maybe but
[Applause]
[Music]
well I got those at your biologist loose
and that why I think we gotta take care
of this planet yes sir
cuz it's all we got yes sir talk to me
no we can't move to Venus oh we got no
damn hot are we alone I can't tell you
without a doubt are you gonna tell me
what
are we alone
I don't know but I'll tell you how we're
going to find out tell you how we're
going to find out well we've got to
explore all the potentially habitable
planets in the solar system anyway where
there is or was liquid water energy
organic molecules this includes the
cause of Venus the subsurface of Mars
the oceans of Jupiter's moon Europa
Saturn's moon Titan is own and even a
possible interior ocean of Pluto
meanwhile 100 million exoplanets in the
Milky Way galaxy for signs of life in
order to do this we need to develop the
next generation of space telescopes and
spectrometers so we can examine those
alien atmospheres and search for the
chemistry produced by life-forms
interacting with their environment these
new instruments will not be inexpensive
but they may allow us to finally answer
the age-old haunting question are we
alone
so in short kids if you want to know if
there are any L is write your
congressperson and tell them to increase
funding for astrobiology I am pretty
sure that everyone can tell exactly
which part I wrote and with heart I
didn't and that was rehearsing a lot or
was
oh good night yeah man that was
fantastic
there's a place is a lot of fun you know
what this legato all-stars is all about
a long one and mike thanks for coming
over you were at the apartment earlier
was that and if you have to share you
with your job every once in a while you
had to sign up but I'm really glad I got
to be here and yeah intrepid the world
war two aircraft carrier parked yeah I'm
a side of Manhattan that has the
enterprise Enterprise authorization a
great other things going on so I was
over there early but happy I got a
chance to be here and see you guys
expect coming over thanks for having me
apart and just two people remember you
were the first person to tweet from
space I was yeah yeah I was and N and so
in 1969 Neil Armstrong said one small
step for man and your first tweet from
space was what not as good they made fun
of me on Saturday Night Live oh really
yeah I said I said launch was awesome
and on Saturday do some said I said
launch what and I said some other things
too but on Saturday night like that
weekend while I was in space right why
would you want a 300 million dollar
spaceship in orbit the taxpayers put you
up there you pull out it what it cost
the first ever has darkly yeah I just
needed a ride need a ride right so you
said this was off the launch was awesome
I said launch was awesome
I'm feeling great the adventure of a
lifetime has begun I wanted the people
of Earth to know I was feeling great
about that way that is not a bad tweet
that's not always if ever they made fun
of it was good they made fun of on
Sunday they go in 40 years there's this
40th anniversary you you hosted the
celebration oh I had in Washington yeah
that was honey and all those guys were
alive by a third more hazy Center I know
actually I'm doing one at the meeting
with one inmate wait a minute was the
40th anniversary of the Apollo emcee of
that event was awesome
yeah we had just come back and I was at
I said 40 years we've gone from we had a
stop we recording anymore not with a
quarter it is one small we've gone from
one small step you know one small step
for man one time
amantha we've got and this is leap day
by the way you know they gently right
now when we came late right and we've
done in forty years ago from that to
launch was awesome if this guy ever meet
aliens this is how we'll find out about
these dudes look alien name a nice one
me so anyway but it is not about of
paying attention to that way Joey good
no wasn't bad so now here's what I want
to know because you aren't in this club
of people who are part of was very
fortunate and people and a very for very
esoteric group that quilt one small step
for man one giant leap for mankind
yeah was that indeed pre-written free
night on internet I an rehearse I asked
the man I just want to know it first of
all I was with him and asked him what's
that not Neil Armstrong man the first
man on the Moon I and he came and spoke
to our astronaut class yeah first week
at NASA
yes and it just so happened around the
like the little buffet thing we had
there he's standing next to me my big
arrow beside my accident yeah right
accident yeah he's standing next Matt I
asked him about that when did you think
as I thought did you ninja hire it I
Republic says well he said he didn't
think about it until after the landing
because he wasn't sure if they were
going to make it and he didn't want to
think about anything before the landing
and he worried about that he thought
about that after they landed think about
that yeah but those guys were not sure
they were going to make an effect the
first three Apollo's right now the first
three were all the same flight so Zane
denote the first guys were going to make
it so they once they made it then Apollo
12 they came up with enough with that
after they landed on the moon on the
moon he came up with that he wasn't
going to think about anything except but
except for the landing badass that is
badass that man I'm impressed yeah I
mean they barely made it any guys ever
areas and just a super amazing pilot
amazing person anyway so it suggests no
I believe really nothing like that did I
tell you you know I mean not maybe we
were like that I'm sure you did their
big fortieth celebration yeah not that
long air not that long after after I
first met him in 1973 Wow where were you
attitude me here wanted now you
in high school man now you want to know
you were like a little kid he's the man
I know you are Luke Neil Armstrong Neil
deGrasse Tyson I met him he like man I
met him is name's Neil - I met him at
the bar
of the SS Canberra fourth largest ocean
liner in the world while I was retooled
to become a floating science laboratory
to go from New York to the coast of
North West Africa to observe on Julie
xxx a seven minute long total solar
eclipse Wow I was on that ship at age 40
what are you three I was 14 yeah I lied
and told her when I was 16 and I had my
own telescope is by myself with you well
there was 18 hundred other people
without your parents so my parents were
I was alone alone and I had my own
telescope and during the eclipses office
is a forest of telescope tripods on the
deck after they'd taken off all the
shuffle boards and ended lawn chairs and
everything that whatever the deck chairs
and so he was one of the sort of
celebrity he'll is that onto the ship
and I hadn't fully appreciated he had
just freaking like Apollo yeah thing had
just ended in 1972 right and so but he
was there no one was hounding him or
anything and and I got him to sign my
little little you know the brochure for
the trip and so that's what it was yeah
yeah that's so cool man so it turns out
his son who's my age yeah on the ship at
the time oh come on friends with the Sun
so yes I had a few mean we we met a few
times I mean yes oh I'm exaggerating
when I say we were like we really like
that no but still I begin in an
encounter with him at that sort of a
yeah you can get in for the higher you
in some way I was already a lot of
problems we're gonna clip screws it's
not a breaking president no I'm going to
be into you
I mean you're gonna fire out of crews at
14 let me ask you to mother when exactly
did I want to know okay because the way
I you know you and I did a thing on CBS
this morning and I said the reason why I
like Neil deGrasse Tyson is because he
talks about the universe the way I talk
about sex and oh no series I'm not even
joking that does it
so what it looks like because I'm going
to explain it up good why because I was
once on Jon Stewart and I was talking
about Mars and I was talking about at
some time and it passed it
it was clearly sort of wet and fertile
and might have had life using these
terms and then John soon as I do that
when you talk about the universe I get
horny right is that what's happening
what oh that was and well I don't know
if I'm getting away you know honestly uh
yeah
so what exactly was the moment if you
can actually call it down to a moment oh
yeah and I want to know this from each
one of you what exactly was the moment
for you personally when you knew my god
this is it
that's not exactly what I said at the
time but yes okay I didn't say my god
that's not what we're not forwarding hey
I got it when I was 9 years old what did
you say I was 9 yeah and I didn't say
anything because I was in the darkened
silence of the Hayden Planetarium Wow
was unfolding well the the lights dimmed
the stars came out and I thought it was
a hoax really I had seen all 12 stars
from the Bronx where I grew up and
there's way too many stars to met huh
there's a nice folks though let me I'll
go along with it and at that moment I
was star struck I have no other way to
say it and I said is this a thing this
is one could do this is this a and it
would take two years by age 11 I had an
answer to that question that adults
always ask children that annoying
question what do you want to be when you
go yeah I said astrophysicist that kind
of shut him up like that like because
because well it's usually I would be a
doctor Oh aunt Matilda is a doctor you
know I say an anti-business
nobody knows it that was it that was
anyone in the family so I think the
universe chose me because I was helped
little that in the president of this
silent darkness the universe grabbed me
and I've known no other pursuit since
you know whenever you let your dog there
now I'll imitate it amazing I was 11
years old universe grabbed me I would
call child tell me other dog differently
my dad University
hahaha so good so now wait where is so
now I'm director of the place
what's an a story because well as small
town New York people don't care that's
not even talking I'd say I was a kid I
was in everyone here in the everybody
where now you're wrong you're not gonna
cry are you well I got a right after I
show our way to a debt to Greece to
Hannah's heart all right so now wait a
minute more stories we got two more
stories and was gonna wrap it up but
seriously because that was that was
fantastic and I think it's really great
for people to hear the fact that and and
I believe this
everyone knows the way you knew everyone
knows it's just that something seminal
must happen to push you in that
direction but everyone knows and what
normally happens is you tell somebody
and they go man so now I just might just
to put closure on this okay even though
my last sentence sounded like closure I
can close it even better okay to this
day every day I walk into my office I
have a duty and an obligation and it is
my honor to have both of those operating
simultaneously to serve the next
generation who walk through those doors
the way the educators and scientists
serve me nice oh man yo man that's yeah
that's nice but I put on that that's
what I'm saying so that's a mission it's
all things so what you're saying is the
inspiration drove you to a mission I
mean seriously so I'm sorry happened
that's amazing it's also it's a man all
right so now okay I survived by the way
by the way my story is not uncommon
among my colleagues which is why I we're
gonna find that out right now that's why
that's why you have that's why you have
like amateur astronomy groups that have
my kids that are part of it okay there's
no other amateur lawyer groups I don't
think they're amateurs neurosurgeons no
no amateur astronomy like experts in the
night sky and it's all ages and we're
all part of it am i lying you're on a
diet but there's no point what you just
said right there okay the fact is we're
sitting here with there are four people
here three of us have extraordinary jobs
and we know who they leave it out
my job now I see her and we know even
are you or extraordinary job so now what
I want to discuss I don't live in New
York here's my point
so boom that's one story astronaut
astrobiologist how does that intermedium
I mean but you you followed a dream to
man you know it's a little different
judgment I don't want to live in a world
certainly not a country where there
aren't comedians yeah who who have
committed their lives to making others
laugh that makes one of us oh good okay
so no I want to know this because it's
important astronaut how did that journey
happen I think I was six years old when
they walked on the moon
alright almost seven there you go a July
20th 1969 to build up to that I can
remember you know that I remember Apollo
10 going down low and not not landing on
the moon but Apollo 11 watch I would
that deserves some statement as a Apollo
10 that's right
went to the moon deployed the moon amanu
the module the module went down towards
the surface right Hubbard and then went
back up and came back to earth right and
I would have said you know I would have
done landed I said you so I can't hear
you you stand okay which we should land
right right see I don't know that I
would have been a good law-abiding
astronaut I think they put fuel in the
ascent stage on our as a stuck there now
but that was that bad I got out of me
when the SS
how to get also very good at and that's
part of the deal with the alarm sir and
he had to come back
the only landed same thing with Mars and
all you got to come back coming back was
not as another launch something else are
going wrong engine don't work you're in
trouble yeah so anyway yeah so politan
and Apollo eight when he first orbited
the moon Apollo 10 when he almost landed
but there's no plan to do that and then
Apollo 11 was the big mission and I
remember seeing that on my TV set and
looking outside in my front yard
and looking at them I mean we saw it on
TV Neil you can remember this you guys
may be too young for this but when you
saw that when you saw that on TV and you
walked out I 12-inch black-and-white TV
little black and white TV black and
white TVs right that's what it was
and it was that I guess the the the EBA
was probably around 9:30 was was night
time close to master of vehicular
activity space the moonwalk moonwalk
thank you they they lon you know they
move up the middle Michael Jackson's
Moonwalker right yeah I've seen the
other moonwalk at that moon at that moon
ceremony had 12 new moon walkers in the
audience I'm really good it was really
awesome to all of them there I had
almost having edits all the living ones
were there right alright so but but I
remember going outside on in looking at
the moon and saying there are people up
there nice and I love those guys like
god those Neil Armstrong and Mike Mike
Collins and Buzz Aldrin and all those
astronauts from that era were my heroes
and I said I want to be one of those
guys and so it's interesting you know I
remember coming to the paid a
planetarium as well when I was a little
kid my parents take me now grew up in
Long Island but for me I want it I
wanted to be one of those people I want
to be one of those guys and I had no
idea that I was going to happen was this
a little kid on Long Island no idea but
I thought they were they were it that's
fantastic so all right there's our last
story funky spoon
Mikey spoon astrobiologist yeah well
similar to to what Mike said actually my
earliest vivid memory actually I mean I
have other early memories but my
earliest really vivid memory is Apollo
11 landing and my parents let me stay up
real late which probably was partly half
of what was as exciting but the
black-and-white TV and seeing these guys
walking on the moon that to me was I
think really a life-changing experience
it was so exciting and it was real it
wasn't fiction it was this adventurous
amazing groundbreaking journey and even
at that at that age I was in fourth
grade
I guess and and I really just my mind
was blown by that I'm definitely a child
of Apollo and that I think sent me on my
life course I became really caught up in
the romance of space exploration
I was really enthralled by the early
planetary missions the first missions to
Venus
the first orbiters on Mars seeing those
pictures come back now I had kind of an
unusual upbringing actually my dad's
best friend when I was a kid was Carl
Sagan and so Uncle Carl wait a minute
yeah dad's bedroom and was Carl Sagan
yeah they were a big they were they were
both Harvard professors and wait a
minute and started this story with a
moon landing well how it started from
the moon landing but but then the fact
that Uncle Carl was involved in these
really this was before he was famous hey
with Uncle Carl this really cool guy you
know and he would come over with like
the latest pictures of you know of Mary
Mariner 9 onions of nebs exactly and and
he was doing this really cool stuff and
then and then also I got really into
science fiction and I think in my young
mind I didn't really differentiate
between like 2001 and you know the space
fiction and the real space stuff it was
all just exciting romantic stuff and it
was the future and when a Space Odyssey
the film the film it was all what we
were going to be doing in the future and
we were going to be you know that was
what it was going to be like and now
here we are in the future and we're not
sending people to Jupiter yet but I've
been able to be involved in spacecraft
exploration of the other planets and for
me that feels in a very real way like
I've been able to in a sense go into
space we were talking about this earlier
with Carter Emmert from the from the
museum who does the the Astro
visualization where even those of us who
haven't carved it on here yet yeah we
have yeah fantastic
Carter does for that next generation
what others
what his counterparts did back when I
went so yeah I could sit here with the
title of director but we got people
actually make that yeah absolutely right
I didn't realize that so those of us who
haven't man would man into space like
you I feel like we anticipated in sway
that's becoming more and more real
because we can visualize it in 3d we
send the machines out they send back
thee not that I mean I still think
there's a role I want people to go to
Mars and stuff but I also think it's
really cool that more and more of us are
participating in this way that we're
being able to actually in some sensory
way experience it and that to me that's
very real I do feel like I have in a way
been able to participate and go into
space part as part of my brains been
there even if my body hasn't been well
you both here for stress yeah let's hear
per se but this is Startalk
[Music]